hi it's silver at again and I got a
request to do a tutorial on Sean boys
alpine village sets so I'm gonna do that
right now
now first of all as always turn the grid
on because it makes building buildings
so much easier since you can tell where
you need to place different kinds of
things and in this tutorial I'm just
going to cover the basic pieces and the
way this app works and I would recommend
getting all of the sets so there are six
alpine village sets in total but I would
actually count shy guys catfish Cove as
a part of the set as well since it
actually includes the same roofs but
then with a different placement the 1'h
placement and some other odds yeah odds
and ends that you can actually use with
the shy guys alpine village set now some
basic things to know about this the
village set one contains some basic
stuff it contains the wooden posts that
you might see people using it contains
the basic stucco walls some other basic
pieces like windows and stuff like you
can as you can see but so basically the
first set is where you get the basic
walls it's also good to remember that
the first three sets are kind of
different than the second three sets for
example you might be able to tell that
these have different textures different
stucco textures and also different roofs
textures so that's something to remember
so the third the fourth the fifth and
the sixth set they have the same walls
and roof pieces but with different
textures and obviously also some other
random stuff that you might use for
buildings now for this tutorial I always
like using the walls in the fourth set
because they're slightly better than the
walls in the first set in my opinion at
least you just have to lay down the base
of the building so I'm gonna do that
right now just gonna create a very
simple shape okay so now if you have
that you have to read kind of think
ahead which kind of roofs you want to go
and use for example I kind of want my
roofs to be somewhere up here so pretty
high so it would be a two floor building
so I'm actually gonna raise the walls of
this already at this stage I always like
to place the sides of the root of their
walls so let's see I think I'm gonna
just gonna use these inclined walls for
aged wood actually no I'm gonna use a 3h
okay I am actually going to add some
things to the side now what buildings
usually have is some brick things on the
sides now there are many sets you can
use for this but the third set of the
alpine village series has these nice
little corner stones and I always like
using these okay so that looks pretty
decent now I think I'm actually going to
add the roof already though I'm not
entirely sure yeah I'm just gonna mess
with the roof now and now something to
remember when it comes to the roofs is
the fact that the roofs in yeah the
second type of roofs they're all in the
6th alpine village set and the thing
with this is you're gonna have to do it
all yourself because as you can see this
is just a very simple roof it's just one
flat piece with nothing on it but if I
open for example the 3h from the second
set which has a different texture and
different shape you can actually see
that there's it's it's very different
you can see that I kind of goes on like
this and it has some wooden planks
underneath it so these are easier to use
but in some cases the second ones just
look better because their textures are
slightly better as you can see but in
this case I'm gonna be lazy and just use
these roofs because they're much easier
to use and now I'm gonna add a roof kind
of thing to this little part because I
just want to close everything off before
I start doing all the extra details like
windows and stuff like that also if you
wanted to do interiors I always do that
before you add the roof you can ant the
walls before you do the interiors but if
you add a roof already it's gonna be
really hard to place anything
let's see now there's one floor texture
that I really like in this back and
that's actually the floor texture from
the
sir it's this wooden deck one it's very
detailed and it looks really nice so I
always like using that and now you might
think that I know cornices over here
which yes it's quite unfortunate there
are no cornices in this pack so you're
gonna have to come up with some other
ways to kind of add some cornice kind of
effects and I've seen people use the
wainscot but that's not used for stuff
like that so that's realistically
speaking it makes no sense so for a
cornice for buildings like this and this
is actually something that I should not
do but I'm gonna do it anyway
that's efteling scent I'm gonna put it
in the description too since it's a set
that doesn't actually isn't actually
supposed to work with the shyguys alpine
village set but if you if you pay close
attention in my videos you'll see that I
often use it in combination with the
Alpine set and this thing actually has I
think it's somewhere over here and yeah
the problem is this thing is all in
Dutch so that's not very nice it's kind
of stupid and I'm sorry for my fellow
dutch men to make a set in dutch and it
should be actually no it's somewhere
else and a set as you can see it's a
very chaotic set it's not really though
I know thumbnails their names don't
really make sense if you don't speak
Dutch okay so you're gonna have you're
gonna want to go into the second part of
the into the third part of this set and
find this little piece and if you make
it brown you can actually use this as a
very nice cornice that that kind of goes
with alpine village as you can see and
that looks pretty cool and now that is
of course a corner piece as well so just
get this piece for the corners and that
looks pretty neat okay now I'm gonna
close that again and open the fifth set
which is pretty much the set now has all
the random stuff all the random fences
and clocks and cool stuff so that's
definitely things that you can
experiment with for interiors but also
little balconies like this and yeah I
kind of like this balustrade so often
use it
and one last thing that I want to do is
it's just something that I want to cover
just for the sake of covering it is the
foundations these houses they often have
foundations made out of this kind of
stone so what people usually do is they
bring it down to one H or two H like
this and kind of cover the entire
building in this so that gives you that
nice little stone border that makes
these buildings look so awesome
sometimes and as you can see you can
kind of see the bricks sticking out over
there but if you add a plug piece like
that that's not going to happen I also
see that I forgot one piece I'm gonna
come back on that one later okay I did
not have a plug over there already okay
yeah there we go okay so now we have a
nice little foundation for the building
as well so that's pretty cool and this
one more thing that you might actually
and if you're interested in it which is
a large Bay this is something that's
really easy to place and do and can
sometimes really make your building to
look great I don't think it will really
fit this building but it's just
something that to always consider
because it's just a great piece but I
don't think it really works well with
this building so I'm just gonna remove
it here might actually use it somewhere
else but no I don't really see that
happening okay now for doors as you can
see the second set has a door in it but
it's not that easy to use and you have
to actually have an opening in a wall to
use it so I always like to use the door
from the third set since you can just
place it anywhere and I think that it
actually covers yes it actually covers
the foundation piece as well so don't
have to worry about weird glitches and
stuff like that because this dorm works
perfectly the only thing I need to do is
kind of make this more Brown because not
just looks better okay there we go
now there are windows and basically
everything in every single part of this
set but the windows in the fourth set
are actually my favorites especially
when you combine them and I'm just going
to talk about these windows for a bit
because you can do some tricks
with them and people have actually asked
me questions about this for example you
can combine these to just make a round
window like that but what you can also
do is actually combine multiple of these
to make a larger window so if you have
for example a large building you can do
that as well and one thing to never
forget is these window boxes
the third set has window boxes too and I
see many people use that but this window
box is a lot more detailed and a lot
better than the other one so I
definitely recommend using this one so
I'm just going to add windows like this
this is a building with two floors so
obviously I'm just going to add two
floors of root of of Windows to this
also I do think this looks a bit boring
so I'm going to remove that okay so
that's pretty good so far but it's still
the building still likes something and
this is a very important point it's the
the framework but like I explained the
first set has some of their posts that
you might use for frameworks but the
fourth set also has framework posts in
it but these are a thicker and easier to
use if you ask me so I always like to
use these it's it's easier if you if
you're getting used to them you can try
using the ones from the first set
because there's somewhat more versatile
and some points but I just like to use
these because they're easier also one
thing to pay attention to though is the
fact that these don't exactly have a
corner placement so I have to kind of
rotate them to get the right placement
and not make them stick through the
building like that now if you're ready
for some interesting stuff you might
also want to try and place these posts
like that actually no place them like
that because otherwise they're going to
be going through [ __ ] and one like that
and then take this X piece and just kind
of connect the two like that that's one
really easy way to add simple framework
to a building and it doesn't take too
much time especially considering the
fact that there's this X piece and it
looks pretty cool sometimes now you can
still add some windows to the sides here
but you might also just want to
fill them up with whatever you can use
site placement windows but I think in
this case I don't really feel like
making anymore building windows so I'm
just gonna do it like this it's always
hard to find a good window for the top
of the building and one that I usually
use is either the round or the arced
window from this set since it's small
it's good enough and it just looks like
a window that you'd have on top of
building so I'm just gonna place it like
that now this part still looks a bit
boring so I'm gonna add some posts to
that and over here as well and also I'm
actually going to add a large window
here okay now everything is pretty much
on the building now but it still looks a
bit boring so now I'm gonna add some
details to the window so first of all I
just want to add window boxes everywhere
now one thing to note about these things
is they're more common among while
higher floors than they are on the wall
base floor so I usually only add these
on either the second floor up and not
really anywhere alone like this okay and
you have the flowers right here now
always remember though to change the
colors of the flowers to some actual
flower colors because otherwise that'll
be brown and you don't want that
happening so I'm just gonna place these
in all of these things and last but not
least something that I talked about
earlier this little window top I always
like to add this to pretty much every
window that I actually can so I'm gonna
add it to that one I'm not going to add
it to the top ones because there is
actually that lower wooden post over
there so that wouldn't look so good you
don't want this thing to go through
other things and glitch and stuff like
that but this still looks pretty cool
now the one boring thing right now is
actually the roof now one thing that I
always talk about is at least in private
to something now one thing that I always
see is many people just leave their roof
as it is and this looks kind of boring
so what I always do is add dormers
that's pretty much also
I say to people when they want to get
feedback on their alpine village houses
or any house actually saying Stormers
are something that's really easy to
place but it really makes your building
look so much better
a roof without dormers that anything is
just going to look boring in any case
but something to remember is the fact
that the first three sets have different
textures than the last three sets so if
you use the roof from the first three
sets like I did don't use any of the
dormers in for example shyguys alpine
village sets before use the dormers from
either three two or one they all have
different dormers you can well go out
and see for yourself what kind of
dormers they have but the first set has
the basic dormer that will fit anywhere
so I'm just going to use this one in
this case okay and it doesn't really
matter if it's low and kind of sinking
into the roof like this doesn't really
matter it's still fine okay and I'm also
going to add some dormers over here too
now one thing to watch out for with
dormers though is don't place too many
of them no dormers makes you a bit make
you a roof look boring but too many
doors in a row just doesn't look right
either and now one last thing that I
haven't talked about yet is the chimneys
shyguys
alpine village has those really
signature chimneys like these now one
thing that you must note about these is
the fact that as you can see there's
somewhat high but then again they're
also a bit too low I can't use it to
build a chimney over here I can use it
to have a chimney sticking out of the
roof like that but I can't use it for
anything else so I I'm just going to
place it over here because I want to
have a small chimney over there but if I
really want to have a real chimney that
actually goes through a war and actually
does some cool stuff like that I'm going
to have to open the third set and either
take the small or the large chimney it
just depends on whatever you want think
I'm going to use their large one with
this one and then just stack it like
that and there you can add a cap and
there you go that's a nice chimney for
it now one thing that I do see is now
that it's kind of blocking the dormer so
I'm actually going to replace that
because
you don't want to have chimneys in front
of dormers that's not really that
doesn't really look well good now at
this point the building is pretty much
finished but one last thing that I want
to talk about is the roof colonies the
shyguys alpine village set allows for
some amazing coloring on the roof and
it's also a very common thing among
Alpine villages so some very nice and
common colors that really work out well
I this shade of green and kind of this
shade of red also works out really well
eisah dentally just used it on a window
that's not good now I'm just going to go
with this red color since it's very
common and it always worked well if
you're in doubt of what color you should
use I just say use this color whenever
you don't know just use this red color
because it's amazing and there you have
it a nice little basic alpine village
house that you can use as a backdrop or
scenery or something along side a road
now this is just very basic stuff so if
you want to build your building yourself
I'd I just say go ahead and experiment
with all the different pieces in shyguys
alpine village set just try and use some
different shapes and stuff and just try
new things it's a really awesome set to
use it's one of the most user-friendly
sets in the game and it's also very
versatile or you can do many things with
it it's called alpine village but it
works with many themes so yeah have fun
with that and also thanks for watching I
hope you enjoyed the video or at least
learned something from it and I'll see
you next time